these are government bonds
even if you know nothing about them you
might have heard treasuries have proven
always to be a reliable Safe Haven
investment recession fears have caused
investors to flee to Safe Investments
like treasury bonds U.S treasury bonds
are a pretty safe investment nothing can
touch them but there's a caveat not all
bonds are the same some let you take a
bit of a gamble by selling them and if
you do like Silicon Valley Bank had to
you introduce the one thing that
everyone says bonds don't have
risk
we break down how the Fail-Safe
investment can fail and why despite that
bonds are still so safe
bonds are ious the government gets a lot
of money from taxes but it spends more
money so it has to borrow money and
that's where bonds AKA treasury
Securities come in you give the
government money and it promises to give
it back at a later date with some
interest
and the government takes this promise
very seriously this makes bonds an ideal
investment if safety rather than a
larger turn is an Investor's top
priority bonds tend to be a popular
investment tool for retirees investors
looking to add some cushion to their
portfolio or parents looking to start
their kids college fund and the bond
market as we know it today can be traced
all the way back to the first world war
from a pistol shot at Sarajevo the first
of the great modern world wars explode
in 1917 the U.S government released
Liberty Loans a type of bond meant to
Garner public support and funds for the
war
people could cash them in typically 10
to 30 years later
ultimately liberty bonds raised more
than 17 billion dollars
that's two-thirds of the funds America
raised for the first World War
it marked the birth of the modern
treasury market and introduced investing
to many Americans we've got another bond
to buy the government issued more war
bonds during World War II after the war
they were converted to savings bonds
it's your future build for it save for
it buy shares in it we still have
savings bonds today like war bonds they
can only be bought directly from the
government and you can't sell them
though you can transfer them to people
as gifts
Merry Christmas thank you the only thing
that could prevent you from getting your
money when you're saving spawns mature
is it the treasury defaulted
okay it wouldn't look like that but the
government defaulting on its debts would
be catastrophic however it's incredibly
unlikely to happen the fact that
everybody thinks that treasuries are
safe helps make them safe investors
around the world just pile into
treasuries that makes it very very easy
for the US government to raise more
money in the bond market this
perpetuates a cycle
people buy bonds from the government the
government spends the money it Issues
new bonds and then it uses some of the
new Bond money to pay everyone back plus
the US government can always raise taxes
or cut spending in order to pay back its
bondholders so the way to introduce risk
to bonds really comes from well you
not all bonds function like savings
bonds take these Securities treasury
bills notes and bonds you can buy in the
primary Market meaning you get them new
in a Government auction
or the secondary Market meaning you buy
them from another seller and unlike
savings bonds you can sell these bonds
to someone else in the secondary Market
before they mature but if you do you
introduce risk so why take a perfectly
safe investment and make it less safe
the benefit of the secondary Market is
that if you need the money you can
always sell the bond and you don't have
to wait 10 years until the bond matures
but if you sell a bond you're not
guaranteed to get the face value you
paid for it that's because a Bond's
value in this market is always changing
in that way the bond market looks a bit
like the stock market
to understand how this risk works in the
real world let's look at Silicon Valley
Bank Silicon Valley Bank was getting a
lot of money in from the tech sector and
it needed a place to put that money so
it bought billions of dollars of medium
to longer term notes and bonds for the
same reason anyone buys them they're a
safe place to park money for a while
however at the time the bank bought
these bonds the interest rate on the
bonds was low if the bank had been able
to hold its bonds to maturity then the
interest rate wouldn't have mattered the
bank would have cashed in their billions
plus interest and that would have been
that instead a few things went wrong to
ease Rising inflation the treasury
increased interest rates and when
interest rates rise bond prices fall
this left a roughly 17 billion dollar
gap between what the bank paid for the
bonds and what their value was putting
the bank in a bad position to get more
cash and buy newer bonds Silicon Valley
Bank had to sell some of their bonds at
a loss in the secondary Market this
helped trigger a run on the bank and led
to its collapse
now this is an extreme example of what
can go wrong in the bond market what
happened to Silicon Valley Bank is not
the norm most people aren't forced to
sell you know billions of dollars of
bonds at a big loss if you have to sell
them early you're probably won't see a
big loss and you could even see again if
interest rates are falling
ultimately there are still no safer
Investments than government bonds stock
prices can go down like four percent in
a day on a day-to-day basis
um you're not you don't have that risk
if you're buying and selling bonds that
you do have in the stock market that's
why they say nothing can touch them well
almost nothing